Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fares, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday, anywhere along the Go network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是 therestishistory.com。搭乘 Go Transit 前往多伦多主要场馆，如百威舞台和全新的罗杰斯体育场。多亏了 Go Transit 推出的特别在线电子票价，10 加元的周末一日通票可在任意周末或节假日提供无限次搭乘，适用范围涵盖整个 Go 铁路网络。而工作日团体票则可在整个网络中提供同样的工作日出行灵活性，两人起价 30 加元，五人团体最高 60 加元。
Buy your online Go pass ahead of the show at Gotransit.com slash tickets. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC optimum points on your first five orders. Shop now at NoFrills.ca. Many as are the great public servants of this nation who have been buried in St. Paul's Cathedral, illustrious as are the soldiers whose remains lie there. Today's funeral of Sir Henry Wilson
在演出开始前，请前往 Gotransit.com/tickets 购买您的在线 Go 通票。No Frills 送货上门。通过 PC Express 从 No Frills 购买杂货并将其直接送至您家门口。在线购物，并在前五笔订单中获得价值 15 加元的 PC Optimum 积分。立即在 NoFrills.ca 购物。在这座国家里，有无数伟大的公仆被安葬在圣保罗大教堂，也有无数声名显赫的士兵长眠于此。今天亨利·威尔逊爵士的葬礼
will evoke emotions far stronger and more burning than those which are customary at the graveside, even of the most eminent and venerated. The thought uppermost in men's minds will be not the distinction of his military services, but the foul crime, the revolting mischance which has cut off so noble a character and so fine an intelligence while they were still at the height of their powers.
将唤起比通常在墓地所能感受到的远为强烈、远为激昂的情感，即使是面对最杰出、最受尊敬的人物也是如此。人们脑海中最深刻的想法，将不是他的卓越军功，而是那场罪恶的谋杀、那场令人发指的意外——它在一个如此高尚的灵魂、如此聪明的才智正处于权力巅峰之际，将他们无情剥夺。
The assassination has horrified the whole civilized world. Whatever measures the government may see fit to take, the responsibility for those measures must rest solely with the Irish nation. For months past, that unhappy island has lain under the curse of Cain. Morally, she is an outlaw, and there can be no hope for her regeneration, unless she can brace herself to cast off the infection which at present threatens to drag her down into complete social anarchy. No amount of goodwill, good faith, and good intentions on the part of Great Britain can be of any avail to her as long as murder is her ultimate political argument. So Dominic, that was The Times on the 26th of June 1922 with a very punchy editorial
这场暗杀震惊了整个文明世界。无论政府认为有必要采取何种措施，这些措施的责任都必须完全由爱尔兰民族承担。在过去的几个月里，那个不幸的岛屿一直笼罩在该隐的诅咒之下。从道德上讲，她是一个法外之徒，除非她能振作起来，清除目前有可能将她拖入彻底社会无政府状态的病毒，否则她的复兴将毫无希望。只要谋杀依然是英国的终极政治论据，大不列颠所表现出的再多的善意、诚信和好意都将对她毫无用处。多米尼克，那是 1922 年 6 月 26 日的《泰晤士报》，发表了一篇极具冲击力的社论。
on the day of the funeral of Field Marshal Sir Henry Wilson. And I guess you would describe that as perhaps pungent, but the circumstances are extraordinary. So who is Sir Henry Wilson? Well, he had been chief of staff of the British Expeditionary Force in 1914. He'd been the chief military adviser to David Lloyd George in the First World War. He had been British military representative at the Versailles Conference. He has just stepped down as chief of the Imperial General Staff. He has been the MP for North Down in Northern Ireland since February 1922.
就在陆军元帅亨利·威尔逊爵士葬礼当天。我想你可以把这形容为尖锐辛辣，但当时的情况非同寻常。那么，亨利·威尔逊爵士究竟是谁？嗯，他在 1914 年曾任英国远征军参谋长。他是第一次世界大战中大卫·劳埃德·乔治的首席军事顾问。他曾担任英国出席凡尔赛会议的军事代表。他刚刚卸任帝国总参谋长职务。自 1922 年 2 月起，他一直担任北爱尔兰北唐郡的下议院议员。
He is reputedly the ugliest man in the British Army and he has just been shot down in cold blood outside his own front door in Eton Place, Belgravia, in the heart of the West End of London. But Dominic, adding to the drama of this assassination is the identity of his murderers of which there are two. You're not wrong, Tom. So first of all, that editorial, I would have loved to have written an editorial like that. That is pungent stuff. Anyway, he has been killed in broad daylight in cold blood in the centre of London by two
据传他是英国陆军中最丑陋的人，而他刚刚在伦敦西区核心地带贝尔格拉维亚伊顿广场自家大门外，在冷血中被枪杀。但是，多米尼克，让这场暗杀更具戏剧性的是他的凶手身份，凶手有两名。你说得对，汤姆。首先，那篇社论，我真希望自己能写出那样一篇社论。那真是辛辣刻薄的东西。无论如何，他在伦敦市中心的大白天，被冷血地杀害了，凶手是
veterans of his own army who have since joined the Irish Republican army. And this just months after the Anglo-Irish treaty that had supposedly ended the conflict in Ireland. So it's not just one of the most shocking assassinations in British history. Beyond that, it is the trigger for a new and deadlier conflict on the island of Ireland, the Irish Civil War, which is an incredible melodramatic story. And it's described by Ronan McGreevey in his fantastic book on this great hatred, the assassination of Field Marshal Henry Wilson MP as Ireland's Sarajevo. So that's why it is more than worthy focusing in on it. An incredible story full of melodramatic details
他自己军队的两名退伍老兵，后来加入了爱尔兰共和党军队。而这距离本应结束爱尔兰冲突的英爱条约仅仅几个月。因此，这不仅是英国历史上最令人震惊的暗杀事件之一；除此之外，它还是爱尔兰岛上一场更新、更致命的冲突——爱尔兰内战的导火索，这是一个令人难以置信的充满戏剧性的故事。罗南·麦格里维（Ronan McGreevey）在他关于这场伟大仇恨、陆军元帅亨利·威尔逊爵士议员遇刺案的出色著作中，将其描述为爱尔兰的萨拉热窝。这就是为什么它非常值得我们关注。这是一个充满戏剧性细节的不可思议的故事，
and brilliantly handled by Ronan in his wonderfully gripping book. I've got good news for you Tom. What? So we are in Dublin, we're in the Four Courts which plays such a massive part in the outbreak of the Irish Civil War and the man sitting next to us is none other than Ronan McGreevey himself. Oh my god so that's who he is.
罗南在他那本精彩绝伦、引人入胜的书里处理得非常出色。我有个好消息告诉你，汤姆。什么？我们在都柏林，在四法院（Four Courts），这个地方在爱尔兰内战的爆发中扮演了极其重要的角色，而坐在我们旁边的人正是罗南·麦格里维本人。哦，天哪，原来是他。
You can see him blushing here. Thank you so much for having me. I really appreciate it. Oh, Ronan, it's brilliant to have you. So we're going to explore Sir Henry Wilson, who you've written about so fantastically, the murder, who killed him, why you regard this as Ireland's Sarajevo and why it is the trigger for the Civil War. So why don't we kick off with Sir Henry Wilson?
你可以看到他在这里脸红了。非常感谢邀请我。我真的很感激。哦，罗南，很高兴你能来。我们要探讨的是亨利·威尔逊爵士，你曾对他进行过如此精彩的著作描写，还有那场谋杀案、凶手是谁、你为什么认为这是爱尔兰的萨拉热窝，以及为什么它是内战的导火索。那么，我们为什么不从亨利·威尔逊爵士开始切入呢？
So tell us a bit about him. Who is he? Well, Domic, Henry Wilson was an Irishman. That's a really important point to state. He was born in Dublin in 1864 but brought up in the Irish Midlands in Currie, Granagh County, Longford. He was an Irish Unionist at a time when that wasn't regarded as a contradiction in terms. And his family had come over during the plantations of the 17th century. One of his ancestors was with King William at the Battle of the Boy. The family would have spent most of their time in Ireland in Ulster,
给我们讲讲他的生平吧。他是谁？嗯，多米尼克，亨利·威尔逊是个爱尔兰人。这是非常重要的一点。他于 1864 年出生于都柏林，但在爱尔兰中部朗福德郡库里格拉纳长大。在当时，爱尔兰联合主义者并不被视为一个自相矛盾的词，而他就是其中之一。他的家族是在 17 世纪大种植园时期来到爱尔兰的。他的祖先之一曾随威廉国王参加博因河战役。他的家族大部分时间都在爱尔兰的阿尔斯特度过，
but his grandfather bought a number of farms in Ireland, including Currie Grain and County Longford, and that's where Henry Wilson grew up in the South. Right, and he's had this incredibly distinguished military career, hasn't he? I mean, lots of people would say he's one of the two or three men who won the war. Yes, that's correct, yeah. Do you think that's... Yes, well, he was I mean, lots of people would say he's one of the two or three men who won the war. Yes, that's correct. Do you think that's... Yes, well, he was the chief of the Imperial General Staff and he was one of the people
但他的祖父在爱尔兰买下了一些农场，其中包括朗福德郡的库里格拉纳，亨利·威尔逊就是在南部那里长大的。没错，他有着极其辉煌的军事生涯，对吧？我的意思是，很多人会说他是赢得这场战争的两三个人之一。是的，没错，是的。你觉得那是……是的，好吧，他是我的意思是，很多人会说他是赢得这场战争的两三个人之一。是的，没错。你觉得那是……是的，好吧，他是帝国总参谋长，他是那些人之一
who put together the joint strategy that brought the war to an end in a hundred days in the autumn of 1918, when a lot of people thought it would drag on at least until 1919. So in June 1919, he's appointed Field Marshal, and he's the youngest to hold that rank in the British Army. He's another Irishman, the Duke of Wellington. And so he can absolutely be situated in that long tradition of Anglo-Irish military men who serve Britain and the Empire more generally. And there's so much about his career that makes him seem kind of almost archetypal. So a bit like, actually a bit like Custer, but also a bit like Churchill. He's not a tremendous student, but he kind of graduates and then he goes
他们制定了联合战略，在 1918 年秋天的百日之内结束了战争，当时许多人认为战争至少会拖到 1919 年。因此，在 1919 年 6 月，他被任命为陆军元帅，他是英国陆军中获得这一军衔最年轻的人。他是另一个爱尔兰人，威灵顿公爵。因此，他完全可以被归入那个长期传统的英爱军人行列，他们为英国和更广泛的帝国服务。他的职业生涯中有很多地方让他看起来几乎具有某种典型性。有点像，实际上有点像卡斯特，但也有点像丘吉尔。他不是一个用功的学生，但他勉强毕业了，然后他去了
off to Burma and he gets slashed across the face by a Dacoit, doesn't he? A Burmese bandit. I'm glad you can pronounce that word better than me. He fights in the Burr War and he, before entering the First World War, in other words, he has seen the expanse of the British Empire and served it. That's right. By 1910 he's the director of military operations and he is looking at preparing the British Army for possible war on the continent of Europe which most people in Britain hope will never come. Wilson is at that stage of his life he's convinced there's going to be a
缅甸，结果被一个达科伊特（Dacoit，缅甸土匪）在脸上砍了一刀，对吧？一个缅甸强盗。我很高兴你能把这个词发音得比我好。他在布尔战争中战斗，在参加第一次世界大战之前，换句话说，他已经见证了并服务了大英帝国的辽阔疆域。没错。到 1910 年，他是军事行动总监，他正在为英国陆军准备可能在欧洲大陆爆发的战争，而英国大多数人希望这场战争永远不会到来。威尔逊在他生命的那个阶段确信将会发生一场
European war. It's not a popular viewpoint to have in the UK. And he's preparing what will become the British Expeditionary Force in August 1914 for deployment beside the French army in the event of a German invasion. And this is exactly what happens. And also we're making perhaps a rather uptight, humorless man. He's not at all. He's actually very funny. He's uproariously funny. And there's a painting of him done during the Paris peace talks. And he said, you know, either end up in Madame Tussauds or in jail.
欧洲战争。这在英国并不是一个受欢迎的观点。他正在为 1914 年 8 月将成为英国远征军的部队做准备，以便在德国入侵时与法军并肩作战。这正是发生的事情。此外，我们或许把一个相当拘谨、缺乏幽默感的人塑造成了这样。他根本不是。他其实非常有趣。他极其风趣。在巴黎和平谈判期间，曾有人为他画过一幅画。他说，你知道的，要么最后进杜莎夫人蜡像馆，要么进监狱。
You know, he looked like, as he said himself, he looked like a blackout. He was quite a vivacious character. On the topic of him being the ugliest man in the army, you have this brilliant detail that that is what is addressed to him on a letter that was sent to him in 1891 and it reaches him. Yes, it reaches him very funny. So let's move through the 1910s because we want to get him involved in Ireland. So his Irishness is really important to him. Yes, it is.
你知道，正如他自己所说，他看起来像个灯火管制。他是一个相当活泼的角色。关于他是军队中最丑陋的人这个话题，你有一个精彩的细节：1891 年寄给他的一封信上就是这样称呼他的，而且信确实送到了他手上。是的，信确实送到他手上了，非常有趣。因此，让我们回顾一下 1910 年代，因为我们想让他参与到爱尔兰事务中来。所以他的爱尔兰身份对他的意义重大。是的，确实如此。
But it's a very particular kind of Irishness. He feels passionately attached to the union of Ireland and Great Britain. And obviously by the 1910s, as we've discussed in our previous episodes, it is an incendiary political issue. And his position on this, certainly in public, could barely be more extreme, is that fair? The Home Rule Bill is due to become a law in 1914. And you have this very serious incident
但那是一种非常特殊的爱尔兰身份。他深深地依恋爱尔兰和英国的联合。显而易见，到了 1910 年代，正如我们在之前的剧集中所讨论的那样，这是一个具有煽动性的政治议题。他在这个问题上的立场，至少在公开场合，几乎可以说是极其极端的，这样说公平吗？《地方自治法案》预计将于 1914 年成为法律。然后你遇到了这起非常严重的事件
called the Curra Mutiny, your Curra incident. It's not an actual mutiny, but it's a putative mutiny in which Anglo-Irish officers like themselves say they will not obey lawful commands of the government if home rule is imposed on Ulster. And this is a very serious development which threatens not only civil war in Ireland, but possibly in Britain too, if the majority of the British army does not implement the government's stance on Ulster. But Wilson, even though he's supposed to be as a soldier, he's supposed to do the government's
被称为库拉兵变（Curragh Mutiny），即你的库拉事件。这并不是真正意义上的兵变，而是一场名义上的兵变，英爱军官之流声称，如果将地方自治强加给阿尔斯特，他们将不服从政府的合法命令。这是一个非常严重的事件，不仅威胁到爱尔兰的内战，如果大多数英国军队不执行政府对阿尔斯特的立场，也可能威胁到英国本土的内战。但威尔逊，尽管他作为一名军人本应听从政府的
bidding, he's actually conspiring against the government and all of this. And he earns the undying enmity of the British Prime Minister, Herbert Asquith, and it really retards his career until the very end of the war. And then when we get to the end of the war, so once he's stopped being involved with the war, when the war is won, obviously as we've discussed in our last few episodes with Paul Rouse, Ireland looms very large in the political consciousness because of course the war of independence is broken out. And through this time, his position, which you describe so well in your book, his position is consistently that Britain should go harder,
调遣，他实际上却在密谋反对政府以及所有这些事情。他赢得了英国首相赫伯特·阿斯奎斯永恒的敌意，这确实阻碍了他的职业生涯，直到战争的最后关头。然后，当我们走到战争结束时，一旦他不再参与战争，当战争胜利时，显然正如我们在过去几集里与保罗·劳斯所讨论的那样，爱尔兰在政治意识中占据了非常大的比重，因为独立战争当然已经爆发了。在这段时期里，你的书里对此有极好的描述，他的立场始终是英国应该采取更强硬的手段，
send in more troops, that they're facing an organised murder gang who are possibly part of a Bolshevik conspiracy, and that basically we're being far too little-livered and we should just crack down much harder. And he says this publicly. He does, yeah. And when the British government is confronted with the IRA in 1919 and 1920, they regard it as a security problem and they don't deign to call it a war. They send in the blackened hands in the auxiliaries to aid the Royal Irish Constabulary to put down this rebellion by the IRA. But Wilson, as the head of the British Army, wants this to be declared a military operation, he wants to see hundreds of thousands of British
派遣更多的军队，他们面对的是一个有组织的谋杀团伙，可能是一场布尔什维克阴谋的一部分，基本上我们表现得太懦弱了，应该采取更严厉的镇压手段。而且他公开这样说。他确实这么做了，是的。当英国政府在 1919 年和 1920 年面对爱尔兰共和军时，他们将其视为一个安全问题，不屑称其为战争。他们派遣了黑黑军（Black and Tans）和辅助部队来协助皇家爱尔兰警察部队（RIC）镇压爱尔兰共和军的这场叛乱。但作为英国陆军总司令的威尔逊，希望将这宣布为一场军事行动，他希望看到成千上万的英国
soldiers in Ireland routing the IRA and he says himself, if they're meant to be murdered, we ought to be doing the murdering. So he's absolutely adamant that this is a military problem that needs to be resolved. Whereas it's obvious from a very early stage to the British government, particularly to David Lloyd George, that this is a political problem. That even if the British were to win a putative victory, it would be a perfect victory because the Irish people don't want them anymore. The British in Ireland, most of Ireland anyway,
士兵在爱尔兰围剿爱尔兰共和军，他自己也说过，如果他们注定要被谋杀，那我们就该去杀人。因此，他绝对坚持认为这是一个需要解决的军事问题。然而，英国政府从很早的阶段就清楚地认识到，特别是大卫·劳埃德·乔治，这是一个政治问题。即使英国人取得了名义上的胜利，也将是一场完美的胜利，因为爱尔兰人民不再想要他们了。爱尔兰的英国人，无论如何爱尔兰大部分地区都是如此，
they don't want them anymore. And David Lloyd George sees this problem from the middle of 1920, that there's going to have to be a political solution here and Wilson doesn't want that. And does the potential of Wilson to create mischief, is this enhanced when he steps down from the military and becomes an MP for the strongly unionist constituency in Northern Ireland and North Down?
他们不再需要他们了。大卫·劳埃德·乔治从 1920 年年中开始就看到了这个问题，即这里必须有一个政治解决方案，而威尔逊并不想要这样。威尔逊制造麻烦的潜力，是否在他卸下军职并成为北爱尔兰和北唐郡这个强烈联合主义选区的一名议员后得到了增强？
Exactly. So he's made a field marshal in July 1919. He is showered with praise, left, right and centre. He's part of the delegation of the Paris Peace Talks. He's at the height of his powers and of the regard from Britain, but he's already falling out with the British government because of Ireland. He doesn't want anything to do. He doesn't believe that there should be any negotiations. At one stage, he's with Lloyd George. Lloyd George says, your fellow Irishmen who I'm negotiating with are next door. And he says, I don't talk to murder gangs, to which Lloyd George responds, nonsense,
完全正确。因此，他在 1919 年 7 月被册封为陆军元帅。他四面八方沐浴在赞誉之中。他是巴黎和平谈判代表团的成员。他正处于权力的巅峰以及英国对他的尊崇之中，但他已经因为爱尔兰问题与英国政府闹翻了。他不想有任何瓜葛。他不相信应该有任何谈判。有一次，他和劳埃德·乔治在一起。劳埃德·乔治说，我正在与之谈判的你的爱尔兰同胞就在隔壁。他说，我不跟谋杀团伙谈话，劳埃德·乔治对此回应道：胡说，
we have to do these things. So that's his attitude. So his four year stint as the chief of the Imperial General Staff comes to an end in February 1922. There's no chance of it being renewed. He's not even talking to the cabinet at this stage. And within three or four days, there's a by-election and he is elected unopposed as an Ulster unionist MP.
我们必须做这些事情。这就是他的态度。因此，他担任帝国总参谋长的四年任期在 1922 年 2 月结束了。没有任何续任的可能。在这个阶段，他甚至不再与内阁对话。在三四天之内，举行了一场补选，他毫无悬念地当选为阿尔斯特联合党议员。
So he goes straight from being the head of the British army to being an MP. And he's already somebody who is a senior figure in British history. This is two months after the Anglo-Irish treaty is signed as far as the British government, most of the British politics are concerned, Ireland is done with now, but Wilson doesn't see it that way and he becomes a sort of focal point for the, as you know, the diehards in the Conservative Party who don't want to accept the settlement. And so what impact does this have on the Irish Nationalists' revolutionaries? Well at this stage, whereas the treaty is very popular in Britain and passes very quickly through the House of Commons.
所以他直接从英国军队首脑转变为了一名国会议员。他已经是英国历史上的高级人物了。这是英爱条约签署两个月后，就英国政府和英国大部分政坛而言，爱尔兰的事情现在已经了结了，但威尔逊不这么看，他成为了保守党内那些不想接受这一和平协议的顽固派的某种焦点。那么这对爱尔兰民族主义革命者有什么影响呢？嗯，在这个阶段，虽然该条约在英国非常受欢迎，并迅速通过了下议院。
So that's how he's viewed in Britain, but what about in Ireland? What's his reputation there? So his reputation in Ireland after he steps down as Chief of the Imperial General Staff, is that he's a sort of paragon of British imperialism who's going around making incendiary speeches in Britain saying that the Irish can't rule themselves and that there is anarchy in Ireland and that the British should go back in and solve the problem once and for all. And of course, this makes them an enemy, both of the provisional Irish government that's
这就是他在英国受到的看待方式，但在爱尔兰呢？他在那里的声誉如何？所以在爱尔兰，在他卸任帝国总参谋长之后，他的声誉是：他被视为英国帝国主义的某种典范，在英国四处发表煽动性演讲，声称爱尔兰人无法自我治理，爱尔兰正处于无政府状态，英国应该重新介入并一劳永逸地解决问题。当然，这使他成为了根据该条约建立的爱尔兰临时政府的敌人，
established under the treaty, but also the British government, they don't want to hear this. And so he's already a marked man in Irish national circles at that stage. All right. So let's move forward to the crucial day. He's become the MP for North Down. He's been the MP for only a few months. On the 22nd of June, 1922, in his capacity as a war hero, he is invited to Liverpool Street Station for a war memorial commemoration. Yes, for the men of the Eastern Railway Company in Liverpool Street and that memorial is still there.
同时也成了英国政府的敌人，他们根本不想听到这些。因此，在这个阶段，他在爱尔兰民族主义圈子里已经是个上了黑名单的人。好了。让我们进入关键的一天。他成为了北唐郡的议员。他当议员才几个月。1922 年 6 月 22 日，以战争英雄的身份，他应邀前往利物浦街车站参加战争纪念活动。是的，为了东部铁路公司在利物浦街的人员，那个纪念碑至今仍在。
Right. So he doesn't know this, but this day, which was already freighted with great emotion, is going to be the last day of his life. Ronan, why don't you take us through the story of the day and the final hours of Samrae Wilson. So there's a meeting, the treaty is split, national style, including Irish nationalists in London, and there is a meeting on the 21st of June in Mooney's pub in Holborn to try and clear the air. And somebody walks in with a copy of the evening paper and there on page six, among the single
没错。所以他并不知道，这一天本来就已经充满了强烈的情感，却将成为他生命的最后一天。罗南，为什么不带我们回顾当天的故事以及萨姆雷·威尔逊最后的几个小时呢？因此，有一场会议，围绕条约的分裂，民族主义风格的，包括伦敦的爱尔兰民族主义者，6 月 21 日在霍尔本的穆尼酒吧（Mooney's pub）召开了一场会议，试图澄清空气。有人拿着一份晚报走进来，报纸第六页上，
paragraph news and briefs, as we call it in journalism, is a notice that Henry Wilson, the following day is going to unveil a memorial in Liverpool Street Station to railway workers who have been killed in the First World War. So there is a motivation among Irish nationalism to have them killed, but now there's the opportunity. And two men volunteer, three men in fact, volunteer to kill Wilson the following day, Reggie Don, Jo Sullivan and Dennis Kelleher. And that evening they go to reconnoiter Liverpool Street Station. They realize that they have no chance of killing him there and getting away. So they decide instead that they're going to go and wait for him outside his house at number 36
在单段新闻和简讯中——正如我们在新闻界所称的那样，有一则通知称，亨利·威尔逊将于次日在利物浦街车站为在第一次世界大战中阵亡的铁路工人揭幕一座纪念碑。因此，爱尔兰民族主义阵营中存在着杀害他的动机，而现在机会来了。两名男子自愿，实际上是三名男子自愿在第二天刺杀威尔逊：雷吉·唐（Reggie Dunne）、乔·沙利文（Joe Sullivan）和丹尼斯·凯利赫（Dennis Kelleher）。那天晚上，他们去侦察利物浦街车站。他们意识到在那里杀了他并逃跑的机会为零。因此，他们决定转而在他揭幕纪念碑后，去他在贝尔格拉维亚伊顿广场 36 号的住宅外等候他。
Eaton Place after he's unveiled the memorial. Right, so he unveils the memorial and then he's gone home. Two of the men, so they are Dunne and O'Sullivan, are waiting for him there. And to give people a sense, this is in Belgravia. It is in one of the most expensive, prestigious parts of London, these white stucco townhouses. What a columns. Yeah. It's a very, very desirable part of the capital's living, which people don't tend to get shot on their own doorstep.
没错，所以他为纪念碑揭幕，然后回了家。其中两人，也就是邓恩和沙利文，正在那里等他。为了让人们有个概念，这里是贝尔格拉维亚。这里是伦敦最昂贵、最负盛名的地区之一，到处都是这些白色的灰泥联排别墅。有什么柱子。是的。这是首都一个非常、非常令人向往的居住区，人们往往不会在自家门廊前被枪杀。
No, they don't. So you talked about a happenstance there. Wilson thought about going straight to the House of Commons after the Liverpool Street Station, but changed his mind. He was going to give a speech. So he decided he will go home and get changed because he was wearing his Field Marshal uniform. He's got his sword, hasn't he? Yes. And he comes back and at 2.30 the cab pulls up outside 36, even place, and Donal and Sullivan are waiting for him. They take two steps forward and they shoot him six times on the doorstep of his own home.
不，他们不会。所以你刚才谈到了一个偶然事件。威尔逊原本考虑在利物浦街车站之后直接前往下议院，但后来改变了主意。他本来要发表一次演讲。因此他决定回家换身衣服，因为他穿着陆军元帅制服。他带着剑，对吧？是的。他回来了，下午 2 点 30 分，一辆出租车在伊顿广场 36 号门外停下，唐和沙利文正在那里等他。他们向前迈了两步，在他自家门廊前朝他开了六枪。
Story goes around very quickly afterwards that the old warrior draws his sword at these brigands but in fact, he never gets that far. There's actually only one reliable eyewitness and he never gets as far as actually being able to draw a sword, but a sword falls out of his scabbard. So hence the myth. They shoot him six times on the doorstep and then these two men run off. One of them kind of hops off, doesn't he? This is the most extraordinary of the many extraordinary things about the assassination of Henry Wilson is that the two men who shoot him are disabled veterans of the first world war and one of them, Joe Sullivan, has lost his right leg at Passchendaele in 1917 and
事后很快流传着这样一种说法：这位老战士面对这些强盗时拔出了他的剑，但事实上，他根本没走到那一步。实际上只有一个可靠的目击者，而他根本没有机会真正拔出剑来，但剑确实从剑鞘里掉了出来。因此才有了这个神话。他们在门廊前向他开了六枪，然后这两个人逃跑了。其中一个人是一瘸一拐地跑掉的，对吧？这是关于亨利·威尔逊遇刺案的众多离奇事件中最离奇的一件：开枪打死他的两个人都是第一次世界大战的伤残退伍军人，其中一人乔·沙利文在 1917 年的帕森达勒战役中失去了右腿，
they basically hobble off. As they hobble off, they shoot two policemen and suddenly there's a mob, an angry mob that are following them. They hijack a taxi and they make the driver drive in the direction of Marble Arch but they suddenly alight from the taxi and they're hit on the head with a number of truncheons and then they're surrounded by the angry mob and taken to George Street police station where they're roughed up and then brought to court. So we've looked at Sir Henry Wilson. Could we just look now at the character of these two men who are Londoners but of Irish stock and British veterans, veterans of the British army.
他们基本上是瘸着腿逃跑的。当他们一瘸一拐地逃跑时，他们向两名警察开枪，突然有一群人，一群愤怒的暴徒在后面追赶他们。他们劫持了一辆出租车，让司机朝着大理石拱门（Marble Arch）的方向开去，但他们突然下了车，头部遭到多根警棍的击打，随后被愤怒的暴徒包围，并被带到乔治街警察局，在那里他们遭到了殴打，然后被带上法庭。我们已经了解了亨利·威尔逊爵士。我们现在能否看看这两个人的性格特点：他们是伦敦人，但拥有爱尔兰血统，是英国退伍军人，英国军队的退伍军人。
Why and how do they end up murdering their own senior officer? Well, one of the great paradoxes of this assassination that Henry Wilson is an Irish born British imperialist killed by two British born Irish nationalists and Reggie Dawn, he's 24, Joseph Sullivan is 25. Reggie Dawn is son of a British army bandmaster. His mother has, both of his sides of his family have roots in Ireland. He's Jesuit educated at St. Ignatius College. Which is Alfred Hitchcock. Yes, with Alfred Hitchcock is right.
为什么以及如何最终谋杀了他们自己的高级军官？嗯，这场暗杀最大的悖论之一就是，亨利·威尔逊是一个出生于爱尔兰的英国帝国主义者，却被两个出生于英国的爱尔兰民族主义者杀害。雷吉·唐，他 24 岁；约瑟夫·沙利文，他 25 岁。雷吉·唐是英国陆军军乐队指挥的儿子。他的母亲，他的家族双方在爱尔兰都有根基。他在圣伊 Ignatius 学院接受耶稣会教育。也就是阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克。是的，跟阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克一样，没错。
And this is very important when he's facing the hangman's rope. He's constantly evoking his Jesuit background to justify what he's doing. He joins the Irish guards in 1916. He's wounded during the German Spring Offense of 1918 and he's invalided out. And he joins the IRA through a circuitous route. So he joins the Gaelic League, which is one of these many Irish cultural organizations in London. He goes to a traditional Irish music session in Stamford Hill and by and by the route from cultural Irishness to political Irishness is very quick. He joins the IRA in September 1919 and crucially when we talk about the assassination of Henry Wilson he's also sworn into the Irish
当他面对绞刑架的绳索时，这一点非常重要。他不断地唤醒他的耶稣会背景来为自己的行为辩护。他在 1916 年加入了爱尔兰近卫军。他在 1918 年德国春季攻势期间受伤并退役。他通过一条曲折的路线加入了爱尔兰共和军。他加入了盖尔语联盟（Gaelic League），这是伦敦众多的爱尔兰文化组织之一。他去斯坦福山参加了一场传统的爱尔兰音乐会，顺理成章地，从文化上的爱尔兰人转变为政治上的爱尔兰人的路线非常短暂。他在 1919 年 9 月加入了爱尔兰共和军，至关重要的是，当我们谈到亨利·威尔逊的暗杀时，他也宣誓加入了爱尔兰
Republican Brotherhood. Because you say that in many ways it wasn't Ireland that he loved but the ideal of Ireland is represented by the Gay Republican Brotherhood. Because you say that in many ways it wasn't Ireland that he loved, but the ideal of Ireland as represented by the Gaelt revival. Yes. There isn't much evidence that they ever spent much time in Ireland, which is very, very interesting in its own right. Then we come on to Joe Sullivan. He's more a typical second generation Irish.
共和兄弟会。因为你说过，在许多方面，他热爱的不是爱尔兰，而是由盖尔复兴运动所代表的爱尔兰理想。因为你说过，在许多方面，他热爱的不是爱尔兰，而是由盖尔复兴运动所代表的爱尔兰理想。是的。没有太多证据表明他们在爱尔兰度过了很长时间，这本身就非常非常有趣。然后我们谈到乔·沙利文。他更像是一个典型的第二代爱尔兰人。
He's one of 12 children from a Fenian family in West Cork. His father is a master tailor in London, and he's very well educated too. He goes to St Edmunds College in Ware which is one of the oldest Catholic schools in Britain and he's one of seven brothers, six of whom who served in the war and this becomes critically important because when they're looking for information about the killers they say the Home Secretary Edward Short goes into the House of Commons and says how could these guys be anything to do with Ireland? They served King and Country in the First World War.
他是西科克一个芬尼亚人（Fenian）家庭的 12 个孩子之一。他的父亲是伦敦的一名裁缝大师，他也受过很好的教育。他就读于位于韦尔的圣埃德蒙学院（St Edmunds College in Ware），这是英国最古老的天主教学校之一，他是七兄弟中的一个，其中六人在战争中服役，这变得至关重要，因为当他们在寻找关于凶手的消息时，内政大臣爱德华·肖特（Edward Short）走进下议院说，这些人怎么可能跟爱尔兰有任何关系？他们在第一次世界大战中为国王和国家服过兵役。
And he's the one who's lost his leg, isn't he? Yes, he loses his leg in Passchendaele in 1970. And he hides bullets. Yes, that's right. So later when he joins the IRA, he goes over to Ireland and his leg is hollow. So he hides three or three ammunition cartridges in the legs. And in fact, when he gets off the ferry, they see this wounded veteran and some of the British troops that are there give him a lift to his... And he has an unexpected resemblance to David Beckham that he has a girlfriend called Posh. That's right Jan, she's asking him where
他就是那个失去了一条腿的人，对吧？是的，他在 1917 年的帕森达勒战役中失去了腿。他藏匿子弹。是的，没错。所以后来当他加入爱尔兰共和军时，他去爱尔兰，他的假肢是空心的。所以他在假肢里藏了三个子弹壳。事实上，当他下渡轮时，他们看到了这位受伤的退伍军人，一些在那里的英国部队顺便载了他一程……他有一个出乎意料的与大卫·贝克汉姆的相似之处，他有一个叫 Posh 的女朋友。没错，简，她问他：
are you? I haven't seen you since you got out of the rehabilitation hospital, what are you at? And it's one of the few letters that survived from her. So there's a whole story here obviously about the Irish in London and the Irish diaspora and their role in Nationalism which you talk about in your book, but maybe we should take this back to Ireland and think about why this ends up having such colossal repercussions in Ireland because of course this is just days before the outbreak of the Civil War. Yes. To answer that question Let's start by asking why does this happen? Who orders it? And this is a sort of mystery that's hung over this assassination, which effectively, I mean, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but you think you've solved. You think you know
你在哪儿？自从你从康复医院出来后我就没见过你，你在忙什么？这是仅存的几封来自她的信件之一。因此这里显然有一个关于伦敦的爱尔兰人、爱尔兰侨民及其在民族主义中的角色的完整故事，你在你的书中谈到了这一点，但也许我们应该把这带回爱尔兰，想想为什么这最终在爱尔兰产生了如此巨大的反响，因为这当然发生在内战爆发前几天。是的。要回答这个问题，让我们从询问为什么会发生这种情况开始？是谁下达的命令？这是一个悬在这场暗杀事件之上的谜团，实际上，我的意思是，我不想把话塞进你嘴里，但你认为你已经解开了这个谜团。你认为你知道
who ordered it. Yes. Yes. Well, to go back to why this happened, there are separate political divides going on in the South and the North. So Ireland is partitioned in 1921. You have Northern Ireland, which still exists. And then you have the Irish Free State, which is set up in provisional form. So it's going to become the Free State in a year's time, provided that there's an election and there's a constitution and that the government is elected. None of these things are regiven, but in any case, the treaty has split Ireland
是谁下达的命令。是的。是的。嗯，回到为什么会发生这种情况，南部和北部正在发生不同的政治分歧。因此，爱尔兰在 1921 年被划分。你有北爱尔兰，它至今仍然存在。然后你有爱尔兰自由邦，它是以临时形式建立的。因此，它将在一年内成为自由邦，前提是有一场选举，有一部宪法，并且政府是选举产生的。这些事情都不是理所当然的，但在任何情况下，该条约都将爱尔兰分裂为
into split nationalist Ireland and two between those who support the Anglo-Irish treaty and those who don't. And at the same time, in the north, there is a civil war of its own going on, which is known as the original troubles that goes on from July 1922 to 1922, where there's a lot of sectarian violence. And there's also a lot of violence between the IRA and the British State forces there like the RIC and the Ulster Special Constabulary. So all of this is going on at that time. And we have in the Free State an election on the 16th of June in which the pro-treaty, those who are
分裂的民族主义爱尔兰，并在那些支持英爱条约的人和不支持该条约的人之间产生分裂。与此同时，在北部，一场属于它自己的内战正在进行，也就是被称为原始动乱的冲突，从 1922 年 7 月一直持续到 1922 年，期间发生了大量的宗派暴力。爱尔兰共和军与那里的英国国家武装力量（如皇家爱尔兰警察部队和阿尔斯特特别警察部队）之间也发生了大量的暴力事件。因此，所有这些都在那个时候发生。我们在自由邦于 6 月 16 日举行了一场选举，亲条约派，即那些
either actively support the treaty or are neutral in the treaty, win almost 80% of the vote. actively support the treaty or are neutral in the treaty win almost 80% of the vote. So the Irish people have accepted the treaty at this election but six days later this shooting happens. And at that stage the anti-treaty side had in defiance of the provisional government had occupied these buildings here the four courts from April and the provisional government at that stage didn't feel that it had the moral or military authority to remove them from the four courts. And when the assassination of Wilson happens, David Lloyd George immediately blames the
要么积极支持条约，要么在条约问题上保持中立的人，赢得了近 80% 的选票。积极支持条约或在条约上保持中立赢得了近 80% 的选票。因此，爱尔兰人民在这次选举中接受了该条约，但六天后，这起枪击事件发生了。在这个阶段，反条约派公然抗命临时政府，自 4 月起就占领了这里的这些建筑物——四法院，而临时政府在那个阶段觉得它没有道德或军事权威将他们从四法院驱逐出去。当威尔逊遇刺事件发生时，大卫·劳埃德·乔治立即将
anti-treaty garrison who are based here in the four courts for the assassination. He writes to Michael Collins that evening saying, basically, if you do not remove the garrison from the four courts, we will do it for you. So here we have the possibility, this is the ultimatum that the British have given to the Irish. So when I talk about it being Ireland, sorry, you have an assassination, and then you have a British ultimatum, same as Austria had an ultimatum to Serbia. The Irish government is now faced with a dilemma. Do we deal with the garrison in the Four Courts or do we risk the British coming back in and a resumption of the War of Independence? So can we dig into some of those sort of nuances?
驻扎在四法院的反条约守军归咎于这场暗杀。他那天晚上写信给迈克尔·柯林斯，基本上说，如果你不把守军从四法院撤走，我们将代劳。所以在这里我们有了这种可能性，这就是英国人给爱尔兰人的最后通牒。因此，当我谈到它是爱尔兰时，抱歉，你发生了一起暗杀事件，然后你收到了英国的最后通牒，就像奥地利对塞尔维亚的最后通牒一样。爱尔兰政府现在面临着一个困境。我们是处理四法院的守军，还是冒着英国人卷土重来、独立战争重燃的风险？那么，我们能否深入探讨一些这样的细微差别呢？
So first of all the split. One of the great complexities of the split is that when the negotiators come back to Dublin the man who has sent them, Eamon de Valera, ends up becoming the leader, effectively, the spokesman for those people who reject the deal that they've come back with. And do you think he'd always set them up that way? It's a perennial question that's asked as to why he did not attend the talks himself. The most cynical explanation is that he knew he wasn't going to get the Republican, that he wanted to blame it on others. But they had promised to come back to him once before they signed anything.
首先是分裂。分裂的极大复杂性之一在于，当谈判代表回到都柏林时，派遣他们的人埃蒙·德瓦莱拉（Eamon de Valera）最终成为了那些拒绝他们带回来的协议的人的领袖，实际上也是发言人。你认为他一开始就是这样安排的吗？这是一个经常被问到的永恒问题，即为什么他自己没有参加会谈。最愤世嫉俗的解释是，他知道自己得不到共和主义者的结果，他想把责任推给别人。但他们在签署任何东西之前，曾承诺过再向他汇报一次。
And they didn't do that because they were supposed to have had plenty of potentiary powers. In other words, they had powers to sign the Anglo-Irish treaty without recourse to him. So it's all very confusing situation. But anyway, they signed the treaty in the early hours of December 6th and then they're back in Dublin and De Valera is absolutely furious that they had gone and done this without him. And he's furious at the actual treaty itself, the contents of the treaty. But there's immediately a cabinet split in favor of the treaty. It's four-three.
而他们没有这样做，因为他们本应拥有全权委托权力。换句话说，他们拥有无需向他请示即可签署英爱条约的权力。所以这一切都是非常混乱的局面。无论如何，他们在 12 月 6 日的清晨签署了条约，然后他们回到了都柏林，德瓦莱拉对于他们抛下他独自去做了这件事感到极其愤怒。他对实际的条约本身、条约的内容也感到愤怒。但内阁立刻就赞成该条约进行了分裂，结果是四比三。
And then it's debated in Dáil Éireann, the parliament, and it's narrowly passed by 64 votes to 57. So there's immediately, there's a public support, there's democratic support for the treaty. The anti-treaty side do not accept the vote of Dahl-Erin and the critical issue here is the oath of allegiance. Right. So this is an interesting thing that I think a lot of people in Britain assume that the critical issue is partition, is the separation of Northern Ireland from the rest of Ireland. Partition is not really a factor in these arguments.
然后它在 Dáil Éireann（爱尔兰议会）进行辩论，并以 64 票对 57 票的微弱优势通过。因此，对该条约立刻存在公众支持，存在民主支持。反条约派不接受 Dáil Éireann 的投票结果，这里至关重要的问题是效忠宣誓。没错。这是一个有趣的事情，我认为英国的许多人认为至关重要的问题是分区，是北爱尔兰与爱尔兰其余部分的分离。分区在这些争论中并不是真正的因素。
Well, it's not even, because not even the British ministers are kind of thinking that Ireland is going to be permanently partitioned. That's not what's on the table. A lot of people, I guess, think the partition is temporary, but the big issue is the oath. And the oath has a sort of toxic quality to some nationalists, to De Valera, for example. He famously says, well, if people want to accept this treaty and swear the oath, the people have no right to do wrong. That's right. You would think the oath, why would you start a civil war over a formula of words, but that's not really what it was about. It was about the measure of independence
嗯，甚至都不是，因为甚至连英国大臣们都没有那种认为爱尔兰将被永久分治的想法。这不是摆在台面上的东西。我想很多人认为分治是暂时的，但最大的问题是宣誓。对于一些民族主义者来说，例如德瓦莱拉，宣誓具有某种有毒的性质。他曾有一句名言：好吧，如果人们想接受这个条约并进行宣誓，人民无权做错事。没错。你会觉得宣誓，为什么会为了几句话的公式而发动内战，但这并不是真正的原因。这是关于爱尔兰国家将拥有的
that the Irish state would have. Remember those in the IRA had sworn to bring into being an Irish Republic. You can't have a Republic if you have an oath of allegiance to a foreign monarch. And this was the critical issue. And this was inserted into the Anglo-Irish treaty by the British and they insisted on it staying in the draft constitution because Collins had drawn up a draft constitution which left the oath out and Lloyd George went mad and said, this can't happen. And why are the British insisting on this oath of allegiance? Because they didn't want Ireland to set a precedent for the rest of the British Empire. It really wasn't as much about Ireland as it was. What's going
独立程度。记住，爱尔兰共和军中的那些人曾发誓要建立一个爱尔兰共和国。如果你对一个外国君主效忠宣誓，你就不可能拥有一个共和国。这是至关重要的问题。这是英国人塞进英爱条约的，他们坚持将其保留在宪法草案中，因为柯林斯起草了一份将宣誓排除在外的宪法草案，劳埃德·乔治气疯了，说这绝不可能发生。为什么英国人坚持这个效忠宣誓？因为他们不希望爱尔兰为大英帝国的其余部分开创先例。这其实不关爱尔兰的事，而是关乎
to happen in India if we allow Ireland to be a republic? What's going to happen in Egypt? What's going to happen in the other countries? So it's really a matter of the British did not want Ireland to be a republic for that reason. And then the Ulta is abolished in 1933, the British don't care at that stage. They don't care when Ireland becomes a republic in 1948, but they cared about it in 1922. And that's just as we're coming towards the break, the split, the split is not just within the politicians, but it's within the army itself the Irish Republican Army in effect important thing for people to think about when we get into the Civil War a majority of the IRA are opposed to the treaty is that right and they are very confident that they will get even
如果我们允许爱尔兰成为一个共和国，印度会发生什么？埃及会发生什么？其他国家会发生什么？因此，这实际上是英国不希望爱尔兰成为共和国的原因。然后宣誓在 1933 年被废除了，英国人在那个阶段并不在乎。他们在 1948 年爱尔兰成为共和国时也不在乎，但他们在 1922 年在乎。正当我们走向决裂、分裂时，分裂不仅仅存在于政客之间，它也存在于军队内部，也就是爱尔兰共和军内部。对人们来说，思考内战时一个重要的事情是：爱尔兰共和军的大多数人都是反对该条约的，是这样的吗？他们非常自信他们会获得更多
more recruits to fight the treaty. In March 1922 they say they're not going to obey the provisional government they don't regard the provisional government as legitimate we have declared for a republic and we will live under no other law. That was what the anti-treaty General Liam Lynch said. So that was their attitude. And they said that they had 80% of the IRA, but it was a very difficult situation for the provisional government. Remember, this is a government that is effectively on probation. And the people who had won independence for Ireland, a lot of them do not accept the provisional government as being legitimate.
的招募人员来反对该条约。在 1922 年 3 月，他们表示他们不会服从临时政府，他们不认为临时政府是合法的，我们已经宣布建立共和国，我们将在没有其他法律的环境下生活。反条约派将军利亚姆·林奇（Liam Lynch）就是这么说的。这就是他们的态度。他们说他们拥有爱尔兰共和军 80% 的力量，但对临时政府来说，这是一种非常困难的处境。记住，这是一个实际上处于缓刑期的政府。而那些为爱尔兰赢得独立的人，他们中有许多人并不承认临时政府是合法的。
A lot of the kind of senior officers in the IRA do actually back the treaty, don't they? And they do that on the basis. So to quote Sean McEwan, who is one of the most famous... One of Henry Wilson's neighbors, yeah. And he said, to me, symbols, recognitions, shadows have very little meaning, because for him, what the treaty would give him would be the legal right to command his own soldiers.
爱尔兰共和军中许多高级军官实际上确实支持该条约，不是吗？他们这样做的基础是：引用肖恩·麦克尤恩（Sean McEwan）的话，他是最著名的……亨利·威尔逊的邻居之一，是的。他说，对我而言，象征、认可、虚影几乎没有什么意义，因为对她（他）来说，该条约将赋予他的是指挥自己士兵的法律权利。
And Collins himself has kind of alluded to this in a similar way by saying that the oath of allegiance, which people in Ireland are kind of tearing themselves up over, he's saying that this likewise is just a form of words and it matters to the English and it's the sugar coating to enable the English people to swallow the pill. So there are kind of people who are casting themselves as realists, both in the government, the form of Collins, in the IRA, the senior commanders who are saying, come on, let's not argue over this. It's just a form of words. That's right. And what's interesting about the Civil War is that the measure of freedom
柯林斯本人也曾以类似的方式暗示过这一点，他说，爱尔兰人正在为之痛苦挣扎的效忠誓言，同样只是一种文字游戏，这对英国人来说很重要，这是让英国人民吞下这颗药丸的糖衣。因此，无论是在政府方面的柯林斯，还是在爱尔兰共和军的高级指挥官中，都有一些把自己标榜为现实主义者的人，他们说：“拜托，我们别为这个争吵了。这只是一种文字表述而已。”没错。而内战有趣的地方在于，
that Ireland got under the Anglo-Irish Treaty meant that within 25 years, it was a completely independent country. I mean, it joined the League of Nations in 1923. It had its own army. This is the 100th anniversary of the first Irish passport being issued. So the substance of the freedom that was wroughten was complete, really. And that's what Collins famously says, isn't it? That it's the freedom to achieve freedom. To achieve freedom. It was indicated in that sense. So the split happens, as you've already described,
爱尔兰在《英爱条约》下获得的自由意味着，在短短25年内，它就成了一个完全独立的国家。我的意思是，它于1923年加入了国际联盟。它拥有自己的军队。今年是第一本爱尔兰护照发行100周年。因此，争取到的自由的实质内容确实是完整的。正如柯林斯那句名言所说，不是吗？这是争取自由的自由。争取自由。从这个意义上说，它是有所指的。因此，分裂就像你们已经描述过的那样，
on the 14th of April, 1922, a group of the anti-treaty IRA men occupy this building that we're sitting in right now, and they are still here when the assassination of Sir Henry Wilson happens. So maybe we should take a break, and when we come back after the break, we can get back to this question of who ordered the death of Sir Henry Wilson happens. So maybe we should take a break and when we come back after the break we can get back to this question of who ordered the death of Sir Henry Wilson and why that matters and then we'll get into the repercussions for the Irish Civil War. Hi everyone, Millie Bright and Rachel Daler here from the Restless Football Daily Brightness. With the Women's Euros underway we want to tell you how we'll be covering the Euros and
发生在1922年4月14日，一队反条约派的爱尔兰共和军成员占领了我们现在坐着的这座建筑，当亨利·威尔逊爵士遇刺事件发生时，他们仍然留在这里。所以也许我们应该休息一下，等休息回来后，我们可以回到这个问题：是谁下令谋杀亨利·威尔逊的？所以也许我们应该休息一下，等休息回来后，我们可以回到这个问题：是谁下令谋杀亨利·威尔逊的，这为什么重要，然后我们将探讨这场谋杀对爱尔兰内战的影响。大家好，我是“休息是福足球日”的米莉·布赖特和雷切尔·达勒。随着女足欧洲杯的进行，我们想告诉大家我们将如何报道欧洲杯，
all the games this summer and also what it means to have a little bit of Daily Brightness in your life. For those of you that don't know, myself and Millie were part of the England team that lifted the Euros in 2022, and we'll be giving all insights and detailed information about what life is like in camp, and what the girls may be experiencing this summer.
以及今年夏天的所有比赛，还有在你的生活中拥有一点“日复一日的灿烂”意味着什么。对于那些还不知道的人，我和米莉都是2022年举起欧洲杯冠军奖杯的英格兰队的一员，我们将分享所有的见解和详细信息，告诉你训练营的生活是什么样的，以及姑娘们今年夏天可能会经历什么。
We will be discussing all the big stories that come out of this summer's tournament, and we'll be cheering on England as they look to defend their title. We'll also talk about our lives outside of the game and what we get up to, whether it's DIY, time on the golf course, highs and lows of football and the challenges that we face
我们将讨论今年夏天锦标赛中所有重大新闻，并在英格兰队力保卫冕时为他们欢呼。我们还将谈论比赛之外的生活以及我们的日常活动，无论是DIY、打高尔夫球、足球的高潮与低谷，还是我们面临的挑战，
and things that we are eternally grateful for. It's going to be an incredibly exciting summer and we'd love you to join us and come along the journey with us. Just search the rest of this football daily brightness wherever you get your podcast. Don't forget to subscribe and also follow us on Instagram and TikTok. Welcome back to The Rest is History. We're with Ronan McGrieve and we're talking about
以及我们永远心怀感激的事物。这将是一个极其令人兴奋的夏天，我们希望你能加入我们，和我们一起踏上这段旅程。只需在你获取播客的任何地方搜索“The Rest is Football Daily Brightness”。别忘了订阅，也别忘了在Instagram和TikTok上关注我们。欢迎回到《历史的休憩》。我们正与罗纳ン·麦克格里夫一起探讨
the assassination of Sir Henry Wilson and the outbreak of the Irish Civil War. So, Ronan, let's just look for a second north of the border to what's now Northern Ireland. This is obviously a huge factor in this. I mean, it's actually oddly absent from a lot of the story of the Civil War and indeed the Irish War of Independence, which seems like a separate story, but obviously it means a lot to Wilson and it also plays an important part in why he's killed, doesn't it? So tell us a little bit about the context of what's going on in the north. The Civil War wasn't first of all about the status of the North because in the Anglo-Irish
亨利·威尔逊爵士遇刺事件以及爱尔兰内战的爆发。那么，罗纳ン，让我们把目光投向北部边界，即现在的北爱尔兰，看上一会儿。这显然是其中的一个巨大因素。我的意思是，在内战甚至爱尔兰独立战争的大部分故事中，它其实奇怪地缺席了，这看起来像是一个独立的故事，但显然这对威尔逊意义重大，而且它也在他被杀的原因中扮演了重要角色，不是吗？所以给我们讲讲北方正在发生的事情的背景吧。内战一开始并不是关于北方的地位，因为在《英爱》
Treaty Article 12 was going to set up a boundary commission which would examine the boundary and redraw the borders between North and South according to the wishes of the people. So the assumption was made that this would include Fermanagh and Tyrone, Derry, South Armagh etc. So there was an assumption on the part of both pro and anti-treaty that Northern Ireland would by and by be rendered unviable. So it wasn't about the civil war, wasn't about that. But in the North, a substantial minority, the nationalist minority find themselves in a state that they feel is inimical to their interests. Northern Ireland is set up in June 1921.
条约中，第12条将设立一个边界委员会，该委员会将根据人民的意愿审查边界并重新划定南北之间的边界。因此当时的设想是，这将包括弗马纳郡、蒂龙郡、德里郡、南阿马郡等。因此，支持条约派和反条约派都假设北爱尔兰最终将变得无法维持。所以内战并不是为了这个。但在北方，一个庞大的少数群体——民族主义少数群体发现自己身处一个他们觉得对他们的利益有害的国家。北爱尔兰成立于1921年6月。
So it's very important to understand that by the time the Anglo-Irish treaty is drawn up, partition is already a reality. And Lloyd George is telling, De Valeri is telling the Irish delegations, this is not up for discussion, but they keep pushing back on it so they get their boundary commission. But there is a huge amount of sectarian strife in the North between July 1920 and July 1922. We have the expulsion of Catholics from the shipyards, you have the burning out of homes, you have a lot of sectarian incidents on both sides. And the Northern government of James Craig
因此，非常重要的一点是，在《英爱条约》起草时，分治已经成为现实。劳埃德·乔治在对德瓦莱拉和爱尔兰代表团说，这不是可以商量的，但他们不断对此进行回击，所以他们得到了边界委员会。但在1920年7月至1922年7月期间，北方发生了大量的宗派冲突。天主教徒被驱逐出造船厂，房屋被焚毁，双方发生了许多宗派事件。詹姆斯·克雷格的北方政府
is struggling to retain control of the situation. So in March 1922, they appoint Henry Wilson as the military advisor to the Northern government. And at the same time, the Northern government brings in the special powers act, which is known the flogging Act, and where they basically can take away the civil rights of anybody they suspect of being disloyal. So the violence reaches a new crescendo in March 1922. The McMahan family are killed. These are six members of the same Catholic family. There is a massacre in Arnon Street. There's a massacre of Catholic children. And all of this stuff is blamed on the Northern government. And for a lot of Irish nationalists, including Michael Collins at the time, Henry Wilson becomes the public face of this crackdown on the nationalists.
正艰难地维持对局势的控制。因此，在1922年3月，他们任命亨利·威尔逊为北方政府的军事顾问。与此同时，北方政府颁布了《特别权力法案》（被称为“鞭笞法案”），根据该法案，他们基本上可以剥夺任何被怀疑不忠的人的公民权利。因此，暴力事件在1922年3月达到了新的高潮。麦克马汉一家被杀。这是同一个天主教家庭的六名成员。阿农街发生了一场大屠杀。发生了一场针对天主教儿童的大屠杀。所有这些都被归咎于北方政府。对于许多爱尔兰民族主义者来说，包括当时的迈克尔·柯林斯，亨利·威尔逊成了这场镇压民族主义者的公开面孔。
Yes, it's odd, isn't it? Because it's slightly unfair because in private Henry Wilson is more nuanced. I mean, it's impossible to be less nuanced than Henry Wilson was in public. But in private, he's a little bit more nuanced. But in public, he's seen by nationalists as the absolute embodiment of what they regard. I mean, they use the expression of Belfast pogrom, don't they? That's right. And there's a sort of sense that he is the hard-faced incarnation of sectarian cruelty. Yeah. But I mean, it is odd, isn't it? Because he's very opposed to the black and tans, for instance. And he's opposed to religious sectarianism, whether it's from Protestants or Catholics.
是的，这很奇怪，不是吗？因为这有点不公平，因为私下里亨利·威尔逊要更有分寸得多。我的意思是，不可能比亨利·威尔逊在公众面前表现得更缺乏分寸了。但在私底下，他稍微更有分寸一些。但在公众眼中，他被民族主义者视为他们所痛恨的事物的绝对化身。我的意思是，他们用了“贝尔法斯特大屠杀”这个词，不是吗？没错。人们有一种感觉，他就是宗派残酷行径的冷酷化身。是的。但我的意思是，这真的很奇怪，不是吗？因为他非常反对“黑黑军团”（Black and Tans），例如。而且他反对宗教宗派主义，不管是来自新教徒还是天主教徒。
Yes. And he always thought that as an Irishman, he was acting in his patriotic interest in keeping Ireland within the United Kingdom. He didn't believe that Ireland would thrive outside the United Kingdom. And he was anti the black and tans, but not for any humanitarian instincts. He believed in military discipline. He felt that the regular army should have been in Ireland. And also he despaired of the sectarian violence. And he really felt that the Ulster Special Constabulary, the best or most notorious version of that, the B Specials, should have been not a sectarian force,
是的。他一直认为，作为一名爱尔兰人，他是在出于爱国主义利益行事，以将爱尔兰留在联合王国之内。他不相信爱尔兰在联合王国之外能够繁荣发展。他反对“黑黑军团”，但不是出于什么人道主义本能。他信仰军事纪律。他认为正规军本该在爱尔兰。而且他也对宗派暴力感到绝望。他真心觉得阿尔斯特特别警察部队（其中最好或最臭名昭著的版本，即“B特警队”）不应该是一支宗派部队，
but drawn from both sides of the community. But that wasn't realistic at that time. And Colin said of Wilson before the assassination, he said, we know only too well the hopes and aims of the orange Northeast Altshaw. They are well expressed to the world with a likely veiled brutality in the language of Sir Henry Wilson. They want their ascendancy to restore. They want the British back, British diehards and the mischief makers of the Sir Henry Wilson breed are leaving
而应该从社区的两边招募。但在当时，那是不切实际的。柯林斯在暗杀事件发生前这样评价威尔逊：“我们对‘奥兰治东北部’的希望和目标再清楚不过了。它们以一种几近掩饰的残酷性、用亨利·威尔逊爵士的语言向世界明确表达了出来。他们想要恢复他们的统治地位。他们想要英国人回来，英国强硬派和亨利·威尔逊这种品种的搅局者正在不遗余力地
no stone unturned to restore British domination in Ireland. And that in a nutshell is the problem Collins had with Wilson. And so Michael Collins, here's an interesting thing that Michael Collins is of course championing the treaty but at the same time he is sanctioning a new IRA offensive in the North that basically is a complete failure, May and June 1922. And the fact that Collins, he's a court man, he's not a northerner, but he's so invested in the idea of the North is really important for you in explaining
在爱尔兰恢复英国的统治。”简而言之，这就是柯林斯对威尔逊的不满所在。因此，迈克尔·柯林斯——这里有一件很有趣的事，迈克尔·柯林斯一方面在捍卫该条约，但同时他又在北方批准了一场新的爱尔兰共和军攻势，这基本上是一次彻底的失败，发生在1922年5月和6月。而柯林斯——他是个科克人，他不是北方人——却对北方的概念如此投入，这对于你解释
who killed Henry Wilson and why. Before we come to that, should we just look at who the various candidates for the person who ordered the killing are before we name the person that you think is the suspect? Okay, so I have four different, there's five really, but one is that the British government did it. Some people think that I don't believe that. I don't think they would have carried it out that way had they done so. The one theory is that Don and the Sullivan took upon themselves to do this.
是谁杀害了亨利·威尔逊以及原因，是非常重要的。在我们谈到这一点之前，在我们说出你认为是嫌疑人的人之前，我们是不是应该先看看下达谋杀令的各种潜在人选？好的，我有四个不同的候选人，实际上有五个，其中一个说法是英国政府干的。有些人这么认为，但我不相信。如果他们真这么干了，他们不会用那种方式执行。另一种理论是，唐恩和奥沙利文是自作主张干的。
I don't believe this to be true. These were men subject to military discipline and their friends and their family have always pushed back against this idea that they would do something as momentous as this without authorization. The anti-treaty IRA who was blamed by the British government, there's no evidence that they did it. They said themselves after Wilson was shot that if we had done it, we'd have admitted to it, but we didn't do it.
我不相信这是真的。这些人是受军事纪律约束的军人，他们的朋友和家人一直都在反驳这种说法，即他们会在未经授权的情况下做出如此重大骇人的事情。被英国政府指责的反条约派爱尔兰共和军，没有任何证据表明是他们干的。威尔逊被枪杀后，他们自己曾说过，如果是我们干的，我们会承认的，但我们没干。
So it's not them. The pro-treaty IRA or the National Army, I don't think the pro-treaty IRA would have done it. I certainly didn't do it because the pro-treaty IRA or the national army, I don't think the pro-treaty IRA would have done it. I certainly didn't do it because the pro-treaty IRA at that stage was the national army. It was the first army of the Irish state that was established. The IRA chief of staff, Richard Mulcahy, was horrified by the killing of Wilson. It was the last thing that this sort of embattled government needed. So we can rule them out as well, which leaves one organization, which is the Irish Republican
所以不是他们。支持条约派的爱尔兰共和军或国民军，我认为支持条约派的爱尔兰共和军不会干这事。我敢肯定他们没干，因为当时支持条约派的爱尔兰共和军就是国民军。它是建立起来的爱尔兰国家的第一支军队。爱尔兰共和军参谋长理查德·穆尔卡希对威尔逊的被杀感到惊恐万状。这是这个四面楚歌的政府最不需要的事情。所以我们也可以把他们排除在外，这就只剩下一个组织了，那就是爱尔兰共和
Brotherhood, the IRB, not to be confused with the IRA, founded in 1858. It's an organization, a secret oath bound organization sworn to uphold an independent republic. So if we come back to Reggie Donne, Reggie Donne was sworn into the IRB by a man named Sam Maguire, who was the OC in Britain at the time. Sam McGuire is very famous in Ireland, but not for any revolutionary activities. For sport. For sport. The most famous trophy in Irish history, or in the Irish Sporting Calendar,
兄弟会（IRB），不可与爱尔兰共和军（IRA）混淆，成立于1858年。这是一个组织，一个宣誓维护独立共和国的秘密受誓组织。因此，如果我们回到雷吉·唐恩，雷吉·唐恩是由一个名叫萨姆·马奎尔的人吸纳加入IRB的，萨姆·马奎尔当时是英国境内的军官（OC）。萨姆·马奎尔在爱尔兰非常有名，但不是因为什么革命活动。是因为体育。是因为体育。爱尔兰历史上最著名的奖杯，或者说爱尔兰体育赛事日历上最著名的奖杯——
the All Ireland Senior Championship Cup is named after him. In London, he had played with Michael Collins, hadn't he? That's right. He was much older than Michael Collins. He was a mentor to Michael Collins. So if you look at this, Sam McGuire has sworn Reggie Dawn and Joe Sullivan into the IRB. And the head of the IRB, the one man who could sanction this attack to kill Henry Wilson, is the president of the IRB. And that man is Michael Collins. Collins orders it, you think.
全爱尔兰高级锦标赛奖杯就是以他的名字命名的。在伦敦，他曾与迈克尔·柯林斯一起踢过球，对吧？没错。他比迈克尔·柯林斯大得多。他是迈克尔·柯林斯的导师。所以如果你看一下，萨姆·马奎尔将雷吉·唐恩和乔·奥沙利文吸纳进了IRB。而IRB的负责人，唯一一个能够批准这次暗杀亨利·威尔逊行动的人，就是IRB的主席。那个人就是迈克尔·柯林斯。你认为，是柯林斯下达的命令。
Can I just ask before we actually move on to the repercussions, what do people in Ireland think of your theory? What's the reaction been like to your argument? Nobody has been able to contradict me because I think I have provided a huge amount of evidence, even in the Prepperback edition of the, I had further evidence from a Martin Wallace, who was a good friend of Reggie Dunn's, which corroborates the evidence that Collins ordered the shooting. I mean, I go into it in great depth, but I do believe it was him. But Ren, can I ask you, let's suppose Michael Collins has ordered the assassination. When
在我问关于后续影响的问题之前，我想先问问，爱尔兰人对你的理论怎么看？对你的论点，大家的反应如何？没有人能够反驳我，因为我认为我已经提供了大量的证据，甚至在平装版的书中，我还补充了一位雷吉·唐恩的好友马丁·华莱士提供的证据，这些证据证实了柯林斯下达枪杀令的说法。我的意思是，我对此进行了非常深入的研究，但我确实相信凶手就是他。不过，罗纳ン，我想问你，假设迈克尔·柯林斯下达了暗杀令。他是
had he ordered it? Had he ordered it before the treaty is signed or subsequent? No, he had ordered the assassination, we believe in June 1922, after an incident called Pettigrew and Beleague, which again was blamed on Wilson, but had nothing to do with Wilson, where the IRA occupied two border villages and the British army used howitzers and forceful war artillery to get them out. So I believe that it happened after that. There is a woman who told a biographer of Collins that she delivered the letter on the mailboat from Euston Station to a guy called Liam Tobin. Liam Tobin delivered the letter to Sam McGuire, who delivers the letter to Reggie Dawn. And then it was just
什么时候下达的？是在条约签署之前还是之后？不，我们认为他是在1922年6月下达的暗杀令，那是在发生了一起被称为“佩蒂格鲁与贝利格”的事件之后，这起事件同样被归咎于威尔逊，但其实跟威尔逊毫无关系——当时爱尔兰共和军占领了两个边境村庄，英国军队动用了榴弹炮和强力重炮将他们赶了出去。所以我相信暗杀令是在那之后下达的。有一位女士曾对柯林斯的一位传记作家说，她把这封信放在从尤斯顿火车站出发的邮船上，交给了个叫利亚姆·托宾的人。利亚姆·托宾把信交给了萨姆·马奎尔，萨姆·马奎尔又把信交给了雷吉·唐恩。然后，
a question of when is the opportunity going to present itself for us to assassinate him. And that's why the notice in the paper is really important on the 21st of June. Before we get into the Civil War, let's just spend a couple of minutes on the aftermath of the crime itself. The funeral is a huge public occasion. I mean, Tom did that reading at the beginning from the Times. It's a massive story. Politicians are horrified when the news reaches the house of commons, you know, they're all standing up and giving these speeches often about a man who they
这就只是个寻找暗杀他的合适时机何时出现的问题了。这就是为什么6月21日报纸上的那则通告非常重要。在我们切入内战之前，让我们花几分钟时间聊聊这起犯罪本身之后的余波。葬礼是一场盛大的公众活动。我的意思是，汤姆在开始时读了《泰晤士报》的那篇报道。这是一条重磅新闻。当消息传到下议院时，政客们都惊呆了，你知道，他们全都站起来发表讲话，通常是针对一个他们
really disliked, but they're still being asked with, who despised Wilson is very shaken and kind of tearful. There's a sense in Britain, I think that something must happen. That's right. There can be, there must be some form of repercussion. Yeah, well, he was the first British MP to be assassinated in Britain since the Prime Minister Spencer Percival, I think in 1812. So assassination was not the British way of doing things.
其实非常厌恶的人，但他们仍然在被追问……痛恨威尔逊的人也非常震惊，甚至有些热泪盈眶。我认为在英国有一种感觉，那就是必须发生点什么。没错。可能会有，也必须有某种形式的连锁反应。嗯，他是自1812年首相斯宾塞·珀西瓦尔以来，第一位在英国遇刺的英国国会议员。因此，暗杀并不是英国人做事的方式。
But as we know from the First World War and from so many other events, that assassination was an occupational hazard for a lot of politicians, three US presidents, etc. So it's a huge shock in Britain. And of course, the British government has to be seen to do something, hence the ultimatum to Collins to get rid of the anti-treaty garrison out of the four courts. And the only evidence that he presented was a copy of a newspaper that Lloyd George had that could be bought on the streets of Dublin. This was the only evidence that he had to link the assassination with Reggie Dunbar. It didn't really matter who was responsible. They had unfinished business in Ireland.
但正如我们从第一次世界大战和许多其他事件中所知，暗杀对于许多政客来说是一种职业风险，三位美国总统等等皆是如此。因此，这对英国来说是一个巨大的震撼。当然，英国政府必须有所作为，以显示其采取了行动，因此才对柯林斯下了最后通牒，要求将反条约派驻军赶出四法院。他提供的唯一证据是劳埃德·乔治手里的一份报纸复印件，这在都柏林的街头就能买到。这是他将暗杀事件与雷吉·唐恩联系起来的唯一证据。谁该负责其实并不重要。他们在爱尔兰还有未了的事。
They were the British government was getting tired of this standoff that was happening in the four courts. They felt it was undermining the treaty and this was their cue to do something about it. And the four courts, which is obviously where we are sitting right now, it's a court complex. It and a huge sort of it's a big hulking building and especially would have been loomed even larger the time so a symbol of power yes and the fact that it's been occupied for. Months yes from april yeah for two months seen by the british and i guess by the provisional government in ireland as a standing provocation yes it's a standing provocation and that's what it was supposed to be, but the provisional government would not take the bait and go in to remove them. So they were walking in and out of the four courts and so on. It was coming to a head when the anti-treaty side also played into the hands of the provisional government by two days after the killing of Henry Wilson, the kidnap,
英国政府已经厌倦了四法院的这种僵局。他们觉得这破坏了该条约，这就是他们采取行动的信号。四法院，显然也就是我们现在坐的地方，是一个法院大楼。它是一座巨大的建筑，尤其在当时，其庞大的身影更显突出，是权力的象征。是的，而且它已经被占领了——几个月，对，从4月开始，对，已经两个月了——在英国人看来，我想在爱尔兰临时政府看来，这是一种公开的挑衅。是的，这是一种公开的挑衅，它本该如此，但临时政府不会上钩并进去把他们赶走。所以他们可以自由进出四法院等等。当反条约派在亨利·威尔逊被杀两天后绑架了
Ginger O'Connell, who's a free state general. And that's the cause's bellaire. That's your trigger to say, you know, to tell the Irish people we're going to get these people out of the four courts. But they don't mention the Wilson shooting because it's not, it's not politic to do so. But of course, standing behind this is the shadow of 1916 and the revolutionaries, including Michael Collins and Eamon de Valera, who had
自由邦将军金杰·奥康奈尔时，事态终于发展到了顶点，这也给了他们开战的理由（casus belli）。这就是促使你（对爱尔兰人民）说“我们要把这些人赶出四法院”的导火索。但他们没有提及谋杀威尔逊的事，因为这样做政治上不合时宜。当然，这一切的背后是1916年的阴影以及革命者，包括迈克尔·柯林斯和埃蒙·德瓦莱拉，他们曾
been in the GPO, where similarly a major kind of architectural symbol of the state in Dublin is occupied. And presumably part of the strategy of the anti-treaty-ites, if we can call them that, is to force those who are upholding the treaty to play the part of the British. That's right. That was part of the propaganda at that time as well. And there was also another school of thought that the anti-treaties garrison kind of half hoped that the British would try and remove them and that that would unite
身处总邮局（GPO），当时都柏林的另一个国家主要建筑象征也同样被占领。反条约派（如果我们这么称呼他们的话）的策略之一，大概就是迫使那些维护条约的人扮演英国人的角色。没错。这也是当时宣传的一部分。还有另一种观点认为，反条约派驻军其实半心半意地希望英国人会试图将他们驱逐，并希望这能使
the pro and anti-treaty side against the British. And remember the British still had a substantial garrison in Ireland. They still had about 8,000 troops. So they could have gone in and removed the anti-treaty garrison themselves. And that's what they were going to do. But the officer commanding in Ireland, Neville McReady, said, you really don't want to start the War of Independence again, you know? And so instead, they encouraged Michael Collins, who according to your theory is actually the
支持条约派和反条约派联合起来反对英国人。请记住，英国在爱尔兰仍然驻有大量军队。他们仍然有大约8,000名士兵。所以他们本可以自己进去把反条约派驻军赶出去。这本来也是他们打算做的。但驻爱尔兰最高指挥官内维尔·麦克雷迪说：“你们真的不想再次挑起独立战争吧？”因此，他们转而鼓励迈克尔·柯林斯——根据你的理论，他实际上就是
person behind the murder of Henry Wilson, to go in and attack these people who the British government are blaming for that assassination. So basically they borrowed two 18 pounder field guns from Marlborough Barracks here and they positioned them on the keys outside here. So just to reiterate, these are British guns. These are British guns and British shells. In fact, one of the reasons that the pro-treaty side wins a civil war is because of the amount of armaments that they get from a country that they were only fighting a year previously. So they get the 18 pounder guns and they position them at both sides of the bridges here and they give the garrison until
亨利·威尔逊谋杀案的幕后黑手——去进攻被英国政府指责为暗杀元凶的人。所以基本上他们从这里的马尔堡兵营借了两门18磅野战炮，并将它们部署在外面河岸街上。所以重申一下，这些是英国大炮。这些是英国大炮和英国炮弹。事实上，支持条约派赢得内战的原因之一，就是他们从一年前还在与之交战的国家那里得到了大量的武器。因此，他们得到了18磅大炮，并将它们部署在这里桥梁的两侧，并给驻军
3.30 in the morning to get out. The garrison don't get out and then they start shelling. This is the beginning of the civil war. We know that now, but even at that time, the provisional government was hoping that the anti-treaty side would come to their senses that they would say, all right, okay, it's all over now. They even let Liam Lynch, the anti-treaty general, go and he thought he would go back to his men in Munster and say, listen, there's no point fighting over this, but actually that's the start of the Civil War. So we will be telling the story of the Civil War in the next episode and we'll also be talking about what happens to Michael Collins, one of the most famous moments in all Irish
直到凌晨3点30分撤离。驻军没有撤离，然后他们就开始炮轰了。这就是内战的开始。我们现在知道了，但在当时，临时政府仍然希望反条约派能恢复理智，希望他们会说：“好吧，好吧，这一切都结束了。”他们甚至放走了反条约派将军利亚姆·林奇，以为他会回到芒斯特的手下那里说：“听着，为这个争吵没有意义。”但实际上，这就是内战的开始。因此，我们将在下一集里讲述内战的故事，我们还将讨论迈克尔·柯林斯遭遇了什么，这是爱尔兰历史上最著名的时刻之一。不过，在本集结束之前，我们为什么不把这两个人——唐恩和奥沙利文的故事做个了结呢。那么他们后来怎么样了？他们被暴民制服，被带进监狱，显然将面临审判。爱尔兰民族主义者中有人在讨论营救他们，因为历史上有很多从监狱里劫狱的先例。
history. But just before we get to the end of this episode, why don't we tie up the story of these two men, Dunne and O'Sullivan. So what happens to them? They have been overpowered by the mob, they've been taken off to prison, they're clearly going to be put on trial. There is talk among Irish nationalists of a rescue because there's a long history of springing people from prison.
嗯，迈克尔·柯林斯本人曾在1919年亲自营救过埃蒙·德瓦莱拉。历史上有很多越狱事件，包括1921年的斯特兰奇斯监狱。历史上有很多越狱记录，但这两个人是英国最通缉的犯人，英国人是不会再犯同样的错误了。所以迈克尔·柯林斯——这也是我相信迈克尔·柯林斯有罪的原因之一——他派了大量的人去试图营救这两个家伙，但他们意识到这是一个毫无希望的企图。于是，其中三人转而萌生了在考斯帆船赛上绑架威尔士亲王的想法。他们去了考斯帆船赛，但因为他们的爱尔兰口音而暴露了，而且由于情报失误，威尔士亲王根本不在那里。
Well, Michael Collins had himself personally sprung Eamon de Valera in 1990. There was a long history, including in 1921, Strangers Prison. There was a long history of jailbreaks, but these were the most wanted men in Britain and they weren't going to make the same mistake again. So Michael Collins, one of the reasons I believe in the culpability of Michael Collins, he sent a huge number of men over to try and rescue the two guys, but they realized that it's a forlorn hope. So instead three of them set upon the idea of kidnapping the Prince of Wales at the Cow's Regatta. They go to the Cow's Regatta, but they're rumbled because of their Irish accents and also because they had faulty intelligence, the Prince of Wales wasn't there.
所以整个行动注定要失败。审判只持续了一天。那是1922年7月18日。之所以这个日期意义重大，是因为在老贝利街不远的地方，蒙巴顿伯爵正与埃德温娜举行婚礼。这非常有趣，因为在1979年，爱尔兰共和军（临时爱尔兰共和军，临时爱尔兰共和军的最新化身）杀害了蒙巴顿伯爵。我认为刺杀蒙巴顿是我们有生之年最接近当年
So the main situation is doomed. The trial only takes one day. It's on the 18th of July, 1922. The reason that that date is significant is because down the road from the Old Bailey, Earl Mountbatten is getting married to Edwina. And this is really interesting because in 1979, the IRA, the provisional IRA, the newest incarnation of the provisional IRA, killed Earl Mountbatten. And I think the assassination of Mountbatten is the nearest thing in our lifetime to what
威尔逊遇刺事件的事件。但这个案件周围充满了各种奇怪的回响和余波，不是吗？因此，唐恩和奥沙利文是由一位名叫特拉维斯·汉弗里斯的大律师起诉的，我从你的书里了解到，他曾在此前奥斯卡·王尔德诉昆斯伯里侯爵的诽谤诉讼中为王尔德辩护，但他却起诉了罗杰·卡斯曼爵士——几个月前我们曾和约翰·班维尔一起做过一期关于他的特别节目。这位爱尔兰裔英国人曾担任英国驻刚果领事，后来成为一名爱尔兰民族主义者，并在复活节起义前夕被处决。毫无疑问，他们被判有罪并被绞死。
happened to Wilson. But there are all kinds of weird echoes and reverberations around this case, aren't there? So Don and O'Sullivan are prosecuted by a barrister called Travis Humphreys, who I learned from your book, had previously acted for Oscar Wilde in his libel action against the Marx of Queensbury, but had prosecuted Sir Roger Casement, who we did a bonus with John Banville a few months back. This Irish, Anglo Irishman who had served as a consul for Britain in the Congo, but then had become an Irish nationalist and had ended up being killed just before the Easter Rising. Because unsurprisingly, they get convicted and they get hanged.
而刽子手正是当年处决……约翰·埃利斯，是的。是的，约翰·埃利斯曾处决过罗杰·卡斯曼，他还曾因处决都柏林的一名年轻医科学生——18岁的医科学生凯文·巴里而闻名，凯文·巴里是因为卷入了一场爱尔兰共和军的袭击而被捕的。他也是爱尔兰共和党神话中的一个非常有名的人物，不是吗？所以凯文·巴里，正如歌里唱的那样，是一个18岁的英俊少年。他被判谋杀三名英国士兵，其中一人实际上年仅15岁。
And the hangman is the same person who had hanged. John Ellis, yes. Yeah, John Ellis had hanged Roger Casement and also had famously hanged a young medical student, 18 year old medical student in Dublin called Kevin Barry who'd been caught up in a kind of IRA attack. And he's also a very famous figure in Irish Republican mythology, isn't he? So Kevin Barry is, as the song goes, a lad of 18 summers. He was convicted of killing three British soldiers, one actually was only 15 years of age. And
鉴于他的年龄，当时有很多呼吁宽恕凯文·巴里的声音，但他们在芒乔伊监狱绞死了他，他成了爱尔兰历史上的一个传奇人物。因此，保罗·罗伯森、莱昂纳德·科恩、都柏林人乐队都曾歌唱过他。而最后，正是同一个人绞死了雷吉纳德·唐恩和约瑟夫·奥沙利文。好吧，那么下次我们将迎来内战的故事以及迈克尔·柯林斯遭遇了什么。当然，如果你是我们兄弟会（“历史的休憩”俱乐部）的成员，你现在就可以收听那一集。如果你还不是，你可以注册。你可以在 therestishistory.com 上宣誓加入。罗纳ン，非常感谢你。这绝对太精彩了。
there was a lot of calls for reprieve for Kevin Barry given his age, but they hanged him in Mount Joy jail and he became a sort of marathon in Irish history. So Paul Robeson, Leonard Cohen, Dubliners have all sung about him. And then he ends up hanging Reginald Dunn and Joseph O'Sullivan. Right. So next time we will be coming to the story of the Civil War and what happens to Michael Collins. And obviously, if you're a member of our own brotherhood, the Rest is History Club, you can hear that episode right now. If you're not, you can sign up. You can swear your oath at therestishistory.com. Ronan, thank you so much. That was absolutely brilliant.
我们周四的下一阶段再见。再见。非常感谢。这绝对太精彩了。我们周四的下一阶段再见。再见。再见。谢谢。再见本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
And we will see you on Thursday for the next leg. Bye-bye. Thank you so much. That was absolutely brilliant. And we will see you on Thursday for the next leg. Bye. Bye. Thank you. Goodbye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们周四在下一阶段再见。再见。非常感谢。这真是太精彩了。我们周四在下一阶段再见。再见。再见。谢谢。再见 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。